oh sorry didn't see you there
I was just laughing at my favorite
moving image on the Internet
oh you're like gifts to ha how about
this one no all right well how about
this wood isn't that funny it's a moving
image so funniest thing on Italy you
guys are not going to believe this
Stalin has cancer do you want to win all
the game computer PI has died at the age
of 69 that's right today we're going to
discuss gifts and where your complete
Lodha generate scumbag for using them
[Music]
that's right I said it first thing you
need to know my gifts is that it's an
acronym for God I flip min-suk I added
the last bit just kidding guys it's
actually an acronym for graphic
interchange formats hmm interesting and
second of all more importantly it's
pronounced gift okay if you're calling a
jiff I don't know what to tell you there
must be something wrong with you
are you straight-up loco but Felix the
creator's call them gifs so it has to be
right to pronounce it okay so just
because you invented something means
you're the literary scholar of how it's
pronounced what if I told you the
creator of cars pronounce it because the
invader of kingdoms pronouncing stupid
makes zero sense you're as dumb as you
look if you think that way don't make me
laugh
stop nope not the gift I can't there's
too funny
do you even know what the verb of jiff
means let's just entertain the idea of
pronouncing a jiff do you do you know
what jiff means do you know you don't
want to know okay miss me with that gay
I'm not discriminating for your strange
sexual desires but no no chipping
allowed okay stop it well it seems like
a bunch of you lobotomize or having
trouble pronouncing the word jiff so
listen up you just call me a lobotomy
see because dr. Theo Jo is going to lay
down some righteous knowledge on you
it's Jeff it's pronounced jiff and you
know what I'm not even saying it's
because that's the way the Creator says
it that's not even a factor just ignore
that altogether there is no J and jiff
there's no reason to pronounce it like
that oh then what about Jin Han to rap
ginger you must have just forgotten
about those right
hey Jo you seem a bit upset could I give
you a gift would you like me to jiff do
something oh I'm sorry
this the G for the acronym stands for
graphics or graphics ah let's see what
other dumb arguments we have yeah you
will bottom.i there's about 1 million
words in the English language and
statistically about 1.9 5% of them begin
with a G that's 19,500 words that begin
with a G on Wikipedia there's an article
that's literally a list of words where a
hard G is used instead of a soft G so
the fact that you can actually create an
article small enough to list them should
clue you in a bit okay well let's
examine that article here's the same
article I found it a list of English
words where G is pronounced
exceptionally oh look give fits in there
wow what a great article that you
sourced wow that really proved your
point really well didn't it there are 61
words on that list let's even round it
up to a hundred a hundred out of
nineteen thousand five hundred is zero
point five percent so you would rather
argue that Jeff is the exception to a
rule that's followed 99.5 percent of the
time instead of admitting that you never
looked up the grammar rule in the first
place oh just because statistically it's
less likely to be pronounced some way
means that it is pronounced that
yeah that definitely makes sense
according to that logic all these words
should be pronounced jekko
Zeke jeez it's the same idea right now
it's less likely to pronounce that way
you doofus you dummy you jump jump you
tell me don't spank your job' butt
well it stands for graphics interchange
format so the G must be hard this is
such a stupid argument that it instantly
makes you sound like an idiot
no it doesn't shut up I made a poll on
Twitter to see what you guys thought it
was the best way to pronounce it
oh look most of you think it's
pronounced with a hard G so that means
statistically it's correct right
and of course Wikipedia is the most
trusted site of all time to get your
sources from what if we look up gif in
an actual dictionary oh look it's what's
the first thing that shows up gif with a
hard G wow that really sure was hard was
it Nate that's right got you guys hard
on the gif face you haters gonna hate am
i right
sure glad we got that settled now let's
move on to the actual issue of the gifts
gifts have been around for a very long
time over 25 years it started off as
cute little baby dancing wow look at
that that's you remember that one only
90s kids will remember how about the
peanut butter jelly banana that was
funny right
gifts used to be so cute and so innocent
look at this that were used to make
websites look good I remember I made a
website just adding a bunch of gifts
great butterflying
you don't see gifts like that anymore
she's your stone look at the amazing
frame rate of this one Wow it's like I'm
truly there love Star Wars gifts they're
the best
well now guess what it is now it's
cancer it's just cancer so much cancer
if you posted a gift in the last 7 days
I got news for you your mom gay that's
just how it is I'm sorry I know what
you're thinking how did we go from this
to this
all this nothing like a good reaction
gift right but you've probably noticed
most popular ones of black people being
dramatic this it's free realistic guys
it is time to stop I don't understand
why people are so fun of using gifts
they're not funny they rarely are funny
or even chuckle worthy but it's still
there spread around everywhere like a
disease I tried myself to look up some
cringy examples of people using gifts
and the only thing that showed up which
people cringing which is cringy in
itself you are what you're trying to
portray that you're against wake up
sharing a gif of you cringing is
cringing go back and post gifs can't
believe this my own GF go it's time to
stop do you know why gifts are so
popular because of the atoll eight of
the internet no I'm not talking about my
channel talking about tumblr it's as if
you need at least ten images at all
times to stimulate your brain to
distract you from the fact that you are
an angsty depressed teenager that's
tumblr essentially congratulations
everyone when someone greets you by name
and you don't recognize them when you're
seated between two people who are
fighting so relatable oh my when you are
expectedly running to a friend you just
heard a rumor about do you have any form
of character by yourself do you really
need celebrities to portray your
emotions and words you literally you're
just so empty that you can't even
express yourself without using the image
in a video and
someone else now I know it's like an
argument that oh you're stealing memes
and gift it's the same thing but you're
not just stealing into Jill you're
stealing the whole character of another
person it's pathetic you're not allowed
to have fun not on this channel bus feed
of course is also a huge problem - why
gifts are so popular can you imagine
studying for years to become a
journalist - then work on a new side of
writing articles called 19 things even
healthy people do that are actually bad
for you spend up to 75 thousand dollars
to get your degree - then being told hey
this is a great article and what you
rode was really great but can we just
add more pictures of celebrities that
are moving in there because your words
were just not adequate enough ignoring
your body and refusing to make doctor
appointments if you're not convinced by
my ideas why gifts are bad don't worry
there are straight-up facts to explain
this as well
gifts were originally popular because
they were efficient gif uses an image
compressing called LZ we which stands
for lulz ORS Wow
just kidding sometimes I just like to
make stuff up
LZ it's a lossless compression algorithm
that likes to download large image
quickly even if you have a slow
bandwidth great yes it was great 20
years ago gifts have now been surpassed
by its superior PNG but I want moving
images we all know that gifts have been
around for a very long time it's an old
format but now that people popularize it
by adding images and moving images to it
that's when it's become clearly an
outdated format don't believe me I'm
gonna link two examples in the
description just click on them alright I
have a pretty fast internet and these
gifts are not downloading unless I open
them individually they'll load quicker
that way the reason why the video is
quicker than the the gif is because it's
around two megabytes instead of the gift
which is 14 megabyte damn Daniel the
video can also start streaming and
doesn't need to download the whole thing
to start playing the video while the gif
needs to download the whole file to
display properly but why
stays because so video compression
that's right if this setup I have with
the camera for example takes very little
space on your computer or at least when
I on my computer because simple
background I'm not moving a lot the way
the video compression works is that it
takes only that the images that changes
in into account it doesn't keep having
to write download this background for
example unless the background changes
which leads to a lot less data to be
wasted
yeh but if you start adding a bunch of
stuff moving on the screen and if I go
all crazy and you add a bunch of
confetti and stuff you'll quickly see
that the quality of the video goes down
quite a bit but this is how it's
possible that we can have so many videos
on YouTube and so long thank you thanks
to the efficiency of video compression
so many things are made possible hooray
it's also very cool when video
compression fails
yeah
the Martian cool and the Martian gray
Justin Bieber I'm with my face then use
it for in our show you the Porky's
projected on an eyeful projected on a
peach dammit stop with the gifts so we
don't need to have any fishing models
there's no reason to purposely be
inefficient okay there is a better
solution that's right html5 elements
it's got hot to play it can loop if you
want to look at this beauty oh please
right away even though the whole thing
hasn't buffered yet and Sam it has
volume control you couldn't pause it you
can choose to loop it if you want to you
can adjust the volume you can easily
download it and you can go fullscreen
with it and the coding for it is also
very simple HTML 5 elements everybody
that's right if you just got schooled oh
snap y'all just got served on the gift
topic what else argument do you have for
using that garbage okay everybody now we
can finally agree on at least two things
alright it's pronounced gif and you need
to stop using them I know it's sad but
all things must come to an end at some
point and I think it's time that we
finally retired this outdated format I
know how am I going to express my life
if I can't express myself through ariana
grande gifts I know it's going to be
tough but you can get through this I
believe in you just think of our Ariana
said herself I just had a bone taken out
of my skull how is your day that's right
that's how I got out of my gift
addiction to stop it stop with this
garbage I don't want to see a single
gift meme ever again in my entire life
where was this that's hilarious
[Music]
good apply what it said so when I'm
taking over you trying to get like
improv it to the face gonna keep it with
a pacing I'm never gonna switch how's it
going broke gotta get it like this when
you wanna hit the flo rida like come
play now drop the top never stop running
pretty city and I've never got a flop
tell me when it go I'm like whenever I'm
done with this pass to Mike the Edgar